- We think of vulnerability
as a dark emotion.
We think of it as the core of
fear and shame and grief
and disappointment, uncertainty.
Things that we do not want to feel right.
I call perfectionism the 2010 shield.
We carry it around thinking
it's going to protect us
from being hurt.
- Yeah.
- But it protects us from being seen.
But how many of you
were raised in families
where you encouraged to get
curious about your emotions
and talk about them
and explore them right?
Versus how many of you
were raised in families
where you were taught, hey suck it up.
- Yep.
- Push through
and get it done.
- Hello a Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one reason to believe
in entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems.
So now open up your
journey today we're going
to learn from best
selling author Brene Brown
and my take on her top
10 rules to success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
ones you guys like best.
And as always as you're watching
if you see something that
really resonates_ with you
please leave it in the comments below
or quotes so other people can be inspired.
And you can win a prize, as well.
And also when you write it
down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself, as well.
Enjoy.
(airplane noise)
(basketball bounce)
(pop music)
- And so my story is
that I am a researcher
and I never thought I would
have a big public career.
And so I did a TED talk
that went very viral.
And in the wake of that
I was kind of everywhere
for a couple of months on every CNN.com,
NPR it was everywhere.
And something it was
something I wasn't used to.
And the marching orders
from my therapist and my husband
were, do not read the comments online.
(laughing)
So I read all the comments online.
It's, so one morning I woke up
and there were two or
three new articles out
and I started reading the comments.
And they were devastating.
They weren't about my
work, they were about me,
they were super personal.
And they were the things
that creative people
play in their mind and then give up
doing what they really want to do.
Like if I asked every single one of you
you would try, what
would you try if you knew
people would never say this about you?
What would that, what would this be?
It would, those were the
comments that morning.
Of course she embraces imperfection,
what choice does she have?
Look at how she looks.
I feel sorry for her kids.
Less research more Botox.
Just mean personal attacks,
the things that really
up until that moment
had
inspired me to stay
very small in my life and in my career
just so I could avoid these things.
So that morning Steve the kids leave.
I say home.
I get on the couch and
I watch eight hours of
Downton Abbey
(laughing)
And when it's over I don't want to turn
off Downton Abbey
because I then, because the
minute you turn off Downton
Abbey it's like soccer practice and dinner
and back to the mean people.
And maybe, should I get Botox?
And maybe you know, maybe if
I stand still when I talk.
So I get my laptop and I do a search for
who was president in the United States
during the Downton Abbey era.
Have you ever done that
like you're numbing with
TV or movie and so when it's over you
just like stay in that space by like
learning more about the actors and
what's going on?
(laughing)
I've been doing this long enough
to know this is like you're
laughing with me, not at me.
(laughing)
So I put it in and Theodore
Roosevelt comes up and a
quote comes up.
And I read it and this is what it says.
It's a quote from a speech
that he gave in the early
1900's of (mumbling)
And a lot of people call it
the man in the arena speech.
And this is the passage that
changed-- changes my life.
It's not the critic who counts.
It's not the man who points out
how the strong man stumbles or where the
doer of deeds could have done it better.
The credit belongs to the person
who's actually in the arena
whose face is marred with
blood and sweat and dust.
Who, at the best in the
end knows the triumph
of high achievement.
And who at worst, if he failed
he fails daring greatly.
So the moment that I read
that I closed my laptop
and this is what shifted in me.
Three huge things.
First, I spent the last 12
years studying vulnerability
and that quote was everything
I know about vulnerability.
It is not about winning
it's not about losing.
It's about showing up and being seen.
The second thing, this
is who I want to be.
I want to create.
I want to make things
that didn't exist before.
I touched them.
I want to show up and be seen in my work
and in my life.
And if you're going to show up and be seen
there is only one guarantee.
And that is, you will get your ass kicked.
That is the guarantee.
That's the only certainty you have
if you're going to go in the arena
and spend any time in there whatsoever
especially if you've committed to
creating in your life you
will get your ass kicked.
So you have to decide at that
moment I think for all of us
if courage is a value that we hold
this is a consequence.
You can't avoid it.
The third thing which really set me free
and I think Steve my husband would argue
has made me somewhat dangerous.
Is kind of a new
philosophy about criticism
which is this, if you're not in the arena
also getting your ass kicked
I'm not interested in your feedback.
(laughing and applause)
- [Interviewer] what does it mean to be
a wholehearted person?
You have actually you know a list
of ten different qualities
that wholehearted people
have in common.
And so cultivating authenticity.
Letting go of what people
think that's the first one
let's talk about that.
- [Brene] It's so hard I
thought doing this research
I thought going into it
you're authentic people
and inauthentic people.
I had I did not find any
evidence of that at all.
What I found its
authenticity is a practice
and you choose it every
day sometimes every
hour of every day.
And it's a practice.
It's not I just like, I am authentic.
It's that when you walk into a meeting
you have to make the choice,
am I going to show up
and let myself be seen?
Am I going to if I can raise my hand say,
Wow you all look super
excited I don't know
what in the hell you're talking about.
(laughing)
You know that's a choice.
- Yes uh huh.
- Right.
And to be make that
authentic choice you got to
let go of.
- Of the faker faker ooh, I say.
Yeah, call it the faker ooh.
But you know what I have found I mean
I consider myself to
be an authentic person
but when I am inauthentic
is when I've allowed myself
to be around people who were not.
And then I have to fake it
to be with them.
- [Brene] Oh for sure, It's contagious
- [Oprah] Yes so they're faking it.
- Yeah.
- [Opah] And then and you
know you're in that situation
when you do that uh huh
that kind of uh huh.
You're laughing at
jokes that aren't funny.
You're pretending to be
comfortable when you're not
and lose your own authenticity.
- Yeah, and I do it.
One of the shocking findings of my work
was the idea that the
most compassionate people
I have interviewed over the last 13 years
were also the absolutely most boundaried.
- [Interviewer] The most boundaried?
- I'll give you the definition of boundary
that I use in the book boundary is simply
what's okay and what's not okay.
What I think we do is
we don't set boundaries.
We let people do things
that are not okay
or get away with behaviors
that are not okay.
Then we're just resentful people.
Me, I'd rather be loving and generous
and very straightforward with what's okay
and what's not okay.
So my question is big B-I-G.
What boundaries need to be in place
for me to stay in my integrity
and make the most generous
assumptions about you.
The generosity can't
exist without boundaries
and we are not comfortable
setting boundaries.
Because we care more about
what people will think
and we don't want to disappoint anyone.
We want everyone to like us
and boundaries are not easy.
But I think they're the key to self love
and I think they're the
key to treating others
with loving kindness.
- [Interviewer] To sustain.
- To sustain.
Nothing is sustainable without boundaries.
When I found you know 12 years of research
11,000 pieces of data I did not interview
in all that time a
person who would describe
themselves as joyful.
Or described their lives as joyous.
Who did not actively practice gratitude.
And for me it was very counterintuitive
because I kind of went
into the research thinking
that the relationship
between joy and gratitude
was if you're joyful then
you should be grateful.
But it wasn't that way at all
it was really that practicing gratitude
invites joy into our lives.
And when I say practice I think this is
this is the part that
really changed my life,
it changed my family the
way we live every day.
When I say practice gratitude
I don't mean kind of like
the attitude of gratitude
or feeling grateful I
mean practicing gratitude.
These folks shared in common
a tangible gratitude practice.
They either kept gratitude journals.
Some of them did
interesting things like at
one, two, three, four like
at 12:30 for every day
they said something out loud
that they were grateful for.
They one of the things that
we do like we say grace at dinner.
And so now after grace we go around and
everyone in my family says
something they're grateful for.
I mean including what's
interesting is when we first
started I have a first grader at first
grader son Charlie and
eighth grade daughter Ellen
and at first I thought and
we've been doing it for a couple
years, now like they're like, oh God mom.
And if there was a little like this is
are you experimenting on us? (laughs)
A little bit of that but
now what's interesting
even after we did it for
like a couple of weeks
that on those crazy busy
nights where we're trying to
like get to soccer and piano and homework.
And Steve and I are just like
we say a quick prayer we start eating
my kids are like whoa,
what are you grateful for?
And it's been extraordinary because
not only absolutely
does it invite more joy into our house.
It also is such a soulful window into
what's going on in my kids lives.
You know so there's some days
my eighth grader will be like,
I'm joyful that there's
a huge thick wall between
my room and my brother's room you know
something just very you know honest.
But there other days she'll say you know
she had a friend his mother recently died
and she said you know for
a month she would say,
I'm just so grateful that you
all are healthy right now.
You know and so not only
did it make us all more
aware of what we had
and more willing to
slow down and really be
thankful for the joyful moments we had.
But it let me know where she
was emotionally in her life.
You know my son is always, you know,
I'm grateful for bugs,
I'm grateful for frogs.
But sometimes he'll say you know,
I'm grateful that you picked me up early.
Or you know, I'm grateful that I finally
understand adjectives you know.
So it's there's a great quote
that says it's not granted it's not joy
that makes us grateful it's
gratitude it makes us joyful.
And it's by a Jesuit
brother a Jesuit priest.
And I guess I was
just amazed to find that
bubble up so strongly
in the research.
It's life-changing.
We think about vulnerability
as a dark emotion.
You know there are a lot of
people who talk about light
or you know positive
emotions, negative emotions,
dark emotions, light emotions.
We think of vulnerability
as a dark emotion.
We think of it as the
core of fear and shame
and grief and disappointment, uncertainty.
Things that we do not want to feel right.
Things that I don't want to be vulnerable
because that means I'm afraid,
that means I'm uncertain.
That means I'm at risk, I'm exposed.
I'm in grief.
So what we do is we armor up
and we say I do not want
to slip into these dark
emotions I will not let
myself be vulnerable.
But here's
what I learn from the research
and certainly put into
motion in my own life
that was
the most life-changing
is that vulnerability is
the center of difficult emotion.
But it's also the birthplace
of every positive emotion
that we need in our lives.
Love, belonging, joy, empathy.
How many of you would agree
that we're in a serious
empathy deficit in our culture today?
Totally, right?
No vulnerability, no empathy.
And a culture where people
are afraid to be vulnerable
you can't have empathy.
Here empathy is not a default response.
If you share something
with me that's difficult
in order for me to be truly empathic
I have to step into what you're feeling.
And that's vulnerable.
So there can be no empathy
without vulnerability.
Why do you think in that
example that I used while
ago daughter comes home
and says you know tears.
No one sat with me at
lunch today and made fun
of what I was wearing.
So-and-so won't talk to me.
They poured my books out of my locker.
And the response back is,
I told you I bought you
all those cute jeans.
Why aren't you wearing those jeans
and pulling your hair back.
Is that an empathic response?
No, it's a shaming response.
Could that shaming
response be, could a mother
who absolutely adores her child
respond with that shaming response?
Please say yes, don't kid yourself.
I mean come on.
If you've got a if you're
a parent sitting in here
then you sure as hell know
the answer to that is yes.
But why, why did that happen?
What where was the
access to vulnerability?
Where was, I mean, where was empathy?
You can't access empathy
if you're not willing to be vulnerable.
So if my daughter comes
home and tells that to me,
guess what I have to do?
I have to reactivate that sweaty palmed
seventh grader who lives inside me.
And I have to go, oh God
that's so hard.
I'm so sorry.
That's happened to me.
That's happened to me when
I was in middle school
and it's happened to me last week.
Let's talk about it.
But you can't get there
without vulnerability.
You can't fake empathy.
Innovation creativity
born of vulnerability.
This is my favorite part I talked about
this admit I did another
TED talk this year
at Long Beach and I told the story
that during 2011 and even this year
after the big TEDX Houston talk went viral
the big calls came from
Fortune 500 companies.
Oh my God we loved your
TED talk, it was great.
Please come talk to all
of our senior leaders.
And it's like okay.
What do you want to talk about?
Like we don't care just
come and talk to us.
Just if you could ixnay the
shame and vulnerability talk.
(laughing)
Every single conversation
barring maybe 10%.
I was like, well what do you mean?
Well we let you know your you're funny
you have this great research.
I think there's a real
fit with what we do.
We just we don't really
do you know that kind of
stuff around here so you could not
mention vulnerability and shame.
(laughing)
So just for fun for
grins I would say, okay,
so what would you like me to talk about?
You know, fourth-quarter earnings
I frickin' don't even
balance my checkbook.
(laughing)
Like I'm not going to talk about that.
So what do we what do
you want me talk about?
Well, the big issue,
creativity and innovation.
Mmm.
And change, we're going
through a lot of change.
It's like okay so vulnerability
is the birthplace of
creativity innovation change.
And the reason that crisis is happening is
because you're not talking
about vulnerability.
Imagine creativity innovation
without vulnerability.
I'm asking you
for a work product
that has never been made before.
That's completely innovative
I need you to be creative and
I need a percent of people
who are going to happen
when I think it's stupid
and not understand it.
No vulnerability there.
Perfectionism what
emerged for me in the data
was that perfectionism is not
about striving for excellence
or healthy striving which I'm for.
- [Oprah] Yeah.
- It's a cognitive behavioral process
a way of thinking and
feeling that says this.
If I look perfect do
it perfect work perfect
and live perfect I can avoid or minimize
shame, blame and judgment.
- [Oprah] You know what I
thought when I was reading this
I had another aha aha
(high five)
- To people.
- This was my other aha
that perfectionism I
never gotten this before
that perfectionism is the ultimate fear.
That the people who are walking around
as perfectionists who have everything so.
- Yeah.
- [Oprah] That they are ultimately afraid
that the world is going to see them for
who they really are and
they won't measure up.
- There's no question
that's that's what it
that's right right that's
exactly what it is.
It's fear.
- [Oprah] Because it's
very different than trying
to be excellent and working
hard and doing your best.
- [Brene] Yeah yeah
and so I call perfectionism
the 20-ton shield.
We carry it around thinking
it is going to protect us
from being hurt.
- Yeah.
- But it protects us from being seen.
Let me tell you this real
story this just happened.
I spoke at HubSpot last week.
Okay 13,000 people in this Lawson
convention center.
It's like 10 minutes before I go on
and I'm making that I look at Twitter
and I'm this person sends
this tweet out that says,
why is Brene at HubSpot?
Why is a@BrenéBrown at HubSpot 2015?
And he just tweeted like love Seth Godin,
love Amy Schumer all these people.
But why is Brene Brown,
and I'm like oh my God
why am I at HubSpot, what am I doing here?
And then I'm like I start sweating and
it's like any with the Convention Center
is like because you
ladies you know I'm like
oh my God what am I doing
on the opening keynote.
I'm like and then he tweets it
again and I'm like oh my God.
And so these are like marketing people
I don't know anything so I
start Googling in my phone
marketing terms 2015.
(laughing)
And great the first time that comes
is incentivize, I'm like
I've got to work that
I've got to work the word
incentive into this this keynote.
I'm like what does that
mean exactly, I don't know.
But I'm going to say
we're going to incentivize
I'm like what is happening
and I have a total crisis of confidence.
Like because you know
shame drives two tapes
not good enough and who
do you think you are.
And like who am I, right?
That's terrible.
And so then all of a
sudden I'm like who is it
because what happens when
you get backed into a corner
my brain is making up the story.
You don't belong here,
I'm like that story's
not going to work because
I'm going on in five seconds.
(laughing)
I'm like so I'm like okay
the best-case scenario attack.
Attack, attack this guy.
Maybe attack them from the stage.
Maybe use that as my opening.
Maybe say like John Doe
asked what I'm doing
here, well let me tell you
all, you know.
And then I click on the tweet
to figure out what his name is
and I accidentally hit
the link in his tweet
and it goes to this page that says,
What is Brené Brown doing at HubSpot?
She's talking about vulnerability
and that's so important.
Here's her TED talk.
(laughing)
Here are her books.
But could you imagine if
I would have got out there
and been like a great fear.
Yes totally.
No and that's a true
story it just happened
because what happens is
when something hard happens
and were captured by something difficult
our emotions get the first crack at making
sense of something.
A bad look, a hard phone
call, a disagreement at work
we think that we're rational
beings we think that cognition
is going to carry us through
and make sense of it.
But it doesn't you know emotions driving
thought and behavior are not even in the
front seat riding shotgun.
They're not even the back seat.
Thought and behavior
and the trunk going hey
and emotions driving.
So the first thing we
do is we tell ourselves
a story that reduces
ambiguity about what happened.
So, oh I'm not supposed to be here,
I'm not good enough to be here.
Men and women who have
the greatest capacity
for rising strong in the
moment something happens.
They hack into that
neurobiological process
of making up a story.
They stop and say, wait a minute
what's actually going on here?
What is what am I feeling?
What do I know for sure?
Because what is a story?
You know there's a name
and research for a story
that has one or two limited data points.
And we fill in the rest with fear.
- Wow.
- It's called a conspiracy.
(laughing)
A conspiracy is a story
with limited data points.
So here's what I know I
know. guy sent a tweet.
I know I'm getting ready to talk
that's all I know.
So now that I'm ready to ruin his career
and use him as a whipping person you know
as I talk, what is going on?
This first step of rising
strong is recognize you've
been snagged by emotion and get
curious about it, that's it.
But how many of you
were raised in families
where you encouraged to get
curious about your emotions
and talk about them
and explore them right?
(laughing)
Versus how many of you
were raised in families
where you were taught, hey suck it up.
- Yep.
- Push through
and get it done.
So the first thing is really
reckoning with emotion.
What am I feeling?
And and what do I need to know more about?
That is a huge, so that
thing that you say like
does something that someone
knows something that I don't
know, do they have
information I don't have?
That's a huge part of the reckoning
we just don't do it.
So in that minute in the backstage
when I was hopping on my
phone I could have just said,
whoa Brene, your like heart is racing
your where your teeth are clenched
and you're going in for the kill here.
What do you know about this?
- Yeah.
- Nothing, you know nothing.
And what if you do everything
who cares who gives a shit?
- Yeah.
- You know there are 13,000 people here
you're going to spend an
hour targeting one guy
you don't know?
Shame is far more likely to
cause destructive behaviors
than it is to cure it.
What we know is that
shame is highly correlated
with addiction, violence, aggression,
bullying.
It's not helpful to be ashamed.
For this reason I think
this is really a core thing
that we need to get our
heads and hearts around
as a culture.
Shame corrodes the part
of us that believes
we can change.
So to chain someone into changing
is like saying to them you
are horrible and worthless
and you're not capable of change.
Get better.
I have interviewed over
600 men and women now
across the country about shame
and across the interviews men and women
with high levels of resilience to shame
share four things in common.
The first is they physically recognize
when they're in shame and
they know what triggered it.
So let's say something happens
at work I make a mistake
or something happens and
that warm wash comes over me.
You know that feeling yes yeah.
We all know it.
(laughs)
If I can physically say
oh my Go, this is shame, I'm in shame
it's very helpful because we are not fit
for human consumption when we're in shame.
We need to pull away and get re-grounded,
take some deep breaths and
figure out how to respond.
One of the things that
makes aim worse is normally
when we're in it, we act out.
For example, the mother that I interviewed
she fills her car up, she
goes into the gas station.
She goes to pay.
Her credit card's declined.
The man shames her in
front of the other patrons
makes her leave her I think
her wedding band and her wallet
and leave with just an ATM card.
So she's filled with
shame, she gets in the car
she slams the door.
When she slammed the door it
wakes up her three-year-old
toddler who's in the backseat
who starts screaming.
What happens next?
She starts screaming
back, "Shut up, shut up."
- [Interviewer] Right.
- So now she's in the shame
of having this credit card
declined, being belittled
in front of people.
And now having to deal with you know the
struggle of, I'm a horrible mom
and why am I taking this out of my child?
So men and women with
high levels of resilience
recognize physically when they're in shame
and what triggered it.
- Okay.
- Then they practice
critical awareness.
How realistic are the
expectations and messages
that we put on ourselves
or that others put on us
that tell us who we're supposed to be.
The third thing is men and
women with high levels of
resilience reach out.
We've got to share our story.
- [Interviewer] So they talk about it.
- [Brene] They talk about it.
You know we breathe through
it we recognize we're in it
and then we call and
say, hey Patricia it's me
you're not going to believe what happened.
Can you listen?
It's hard.
And then we speak shame you know
it's I try to explain
to people the importance
of using the word shame.
And this is not just laypeople
this is mental health professionals.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- You know we've got to use the word.
It's different if I were
to call you and say,
Oh Patricia Brene is so embarrassed
that would be one thing right?
But if I were to call you and say,
Patricia, it's Brene I'm really
struggling with some shame
that's different.
- [Interviewer] It's a
different conversation.
- Right.
Shame cannot hold on when we name it.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- So it's not just you know
it's an academic pet peeve
I want everybody to get
the semantics correct.
Men and women with high
levels of shame resilience
use the word and talk about the emotion.
I think there's like a thin film of terror
wrapped around us.
And so if it's not
I'm not safe enough,
I'm not secure enough.
It's, I'm not liked enough,
I'm not promoted enough,
I'm not loved enough.
- [Oprah] I don't have enough.
- I don't have enough.
- I am not enough.
- At the very bottom.
- [Oprah] Yeah.
- That's not enough.
- Well that's big beg beg beg beg.
Somebody ring some bells.
We need some bells to ring on this show.
- [Brene] Well that's it and
so guess what the number one
casualty is of a scarcity culture.
- [Oprah] What?
- [Brene] Vulnerability.
- [Oprah] We shut down.
- [Brene] We shut down.
- Because I'm not going to let you know.
- [Brene] No.
- Because I don't
I'm not all together.
- [Brene] Right.
- Yeah.
- And the thing is
that people like oh well we
lose a little vulnerability
but vulnerability is not
just about fear and grief
and disappointment.
It's the birthplace of
everything we're hungry for:
- [Oprah] Creativity.
- Joy, creativity, faith,
love.
- Innovation.
And all of that, yes.
- And the whole thing is
there is no innovation
and creativity without failure.
Period.
- So we got to be open enough
to take the risk to fail.
- Yeah.
- What I have found in
my life and what I found
in my research which
fueled what I did in my life
is that the people who have the most
courage who are willing to show them
be the most vulnerable
are the ones who are very clear
about who the critics are.
The ones who reserve
seats for them and say,
I hear you, I get it, I know
where the messaging is coming from.
I'm not I'm not an I'm
not buying it anymore.
So to get very clear
the last thing which I think
is the hardest is this,
one of these seats
needs to be reserved for you.
One of these seats needs
to be reserved for me.
I need when we look up
and we're putting an idea
our piece of art, our design forward
who do you think the biggest critic in the
arena normally is?
Yourself.
And so definitely me
like I have never watched
either of those TED Talks
because it's not in
service of the work for me.
And I try to do things are only
in service of my work
because what would what would
it serve for me to watch it.
I would sit there and go, oh my God
suck in your stomach.
Oh my God that's not what
you were going to say.
You know we're so self-critical.
And one of the things that I think happens
and I think this happens a lot
it happens in different professions
but I think I see it a lot with creatives
is there is an ideal of
what you're supposed to be.
And what a lot of us end
up doing is we orphan
the parts ourselves
that don't fit what that
ideal is supposed to be.
And what it leaves, when we
orphan all those parts of us
is it just leaves the critic.
And so reserved in this seat is this.
Where we came from.
How we started.
Our families, that's me
the oldest, of course.
(laughing)
The lost years.
The years where I was so lost and confused
and hurt and disillusioned
that I thought the only path to freedom
was a Flock of Seagulls haircut.
(laughing)
The higher the hair the
closer to God we say in Texas.
(laughing)
The people who love us,
the moments that make us
who we are.
And in that chair should be this person.
The person who believes
in what we're doing
and why we're doing it.
And the person who says,
yeah it's so scary to show up.
It feels dangerous to be seen.
It's terrifying.
But it is not as scary,
dangerous, or terrifying
as getting to the end of our lives
and thinking, what if
I would have shown up?
What would have been different?
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed, cast your vote on
who you want to see in the next top 10.
Check out the link in the description
and go vote for the
person that you want me to
profile next.
I'd also like to know
which Clips resonates
the most with you.
What you keep from this
video and immediately
apply to your life or to business somehow
leave it down the comments below.
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Lucille Kate Natura
thank you so much Lucille for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and posting
the picture on Instagram.
I really really really
appreciate your support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed them.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you teach to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love
I'll see you soon.
(airplane flying)
(basketball bounce)
- We numb vulnerability.
When we're waiting for the call.
When we're trying to think about
if we're going, you know, it was funny.
I guess Wednesday I sent
something out on Twitter
on Twitter and on Facebook
that says, what how would you
define vulnerability, what
makes you feel vulnerable?
And within an hour and a half
I had 150 responses.
Because I wanted to know
you know what's out there.
Having to ask my husband
for help because I'm sick
and we're newly married.
Initiating sex with my husband.
Initiating sex with my wife.
Being turned down.
Asking someone out.
Waiting for the doctor to call back.
Getting laid off.
Laying off people.
This is the world we live in.
We live in a vulnerable world.
And one of the ways we deal with it is
we numb vulnerability.
And I think there's evidence,
and it's not the only
reason this evidence exists.
But I think that there
is a huge cause we are
the most in debt,
obese,
addicted
and medicated adult cohort in US history.
The problem is why?
The problem is and I learned
this from the research
that you cannot selectively numb emotion.
You can't say, here's the bad stuff.
Here's vulnerability,
here's grief, here's shame,
here's fear, here's disappointment.
I don't want to feel these.
I'm going to have a couple of beers
and a banana nut muffin.
(laughing)
I don't want to feel these.
And I know that I know
that's knowing laughter
I hack into your lives for a living,
I know that's (laughs) God.
(laughing)
You can't numb those hard feelings
without numbing the
other effects or emotion.
You cannot selectively numb.
So when we numb those
we numb joy.
We numb gratitude.
We numb happiness.
And then we are miserable
and we are looking for
purpose and meaning.
And then we feel vulnerable so then
we have a couple of beers
and a banana nut muffin.
And it becomes this dangerous cycle.
One of the things that I think
that we need to think about is
why in hell we numb.
And it doesn't just have to be addiction.
The other thing we do is we
make everything that's uncertain
certain.
Religion has gone from a belief
in faith and mystery to certainty.
I'm right, you're wrong, shut up.
That's it.
Just certain.
The more afraid we are
the more vulnerable we are
the more afraid we are.
This is what politics looks like today
there's no discourse anymore.
There's no conversation.
There's just blame, you know what blame
you know how blame is
described in the research?
A way to discharge pain and discomfort.
We perfect.
Now let me check if there's
anyone who wants their life
to look like this
it would be me.
But it doesn't work
because what we do is we
take fat from our butts
and put it in our cheeks.
(laughing)
Which doesn't which
just I hope in 100 years
people will look back and go, wow.
(laughing)
And we perfect most
dangerously our children.
Let me tell you what we think about
let me thank you very
quickly about children.
They're hardwired for
struggle when they get here.
When you hold those perfect
little babies in your hand
our job is not to say,
look at them, look at her,
she's perfect.
My job is just to keep her perfect
make sure she makes the
tennis team by fifth grade
and Yale by seventh grade.
(laughing)
Our job, that's not our job.
Our job is to look and say
you know what you're imperfect
and you're wired for struggle
but you are worthy of love and belonging.
That's our job.
Show me a generation of
kids raised like that
and we'll end the problems
I think that we see today.
We pretend
that what we do doesn't
have an effect on people.
We do that in our personal lives,
we do that corporate.
Whether it's a bailout, an oil spill.
A recall
we pretend like what we're
doing doesn't have a huge impact
on other people.
Yeah I would say to
companies if this is not
our first rodeo people.
We just need you to be authentic and real
and say
we're sorry.
We'll fix it.
But there's another way and
I'll leave you with this.
This is what I have found.
To let ourselves be seen.
Deeply seen.
Vulnerably seen.
To love with our whole hearts
even though there's no guarantee.
And that's really hard I
can tell you as a parent
that's excruciatingly difficult.
To practice gratitude and joy
in those moments of kind of terror
when we're wondering,
can I love you this much?
Can I believe in this as passionately?
Can I be this fierce about this?
Just to be able to stop and
instead of catastrophizing
what might happen to say,
I'm just so grateful.
Because to feel this
vulnerable means I'm alive.
And the last, which I think is
probably the most important,
is to believe that we're enough.
Because when we work from
a place I believe that says
I'm enough,
then we stop screaming
and start listening.
We're kinder and gentler
to the people around us
and we're kinder and gentler to ourselves.
That's all I have.